[Musique]
on se croirait presque à new york
on est sur la rue peel à montréal et on
vient d'acheter un gâteau au fromage
japonaise saori on est dans une toute
petit truc très peu de gens connaissent
en plein coeur de montréal devant oncle
ted qui ont tous les persos ont coûté
tout c'est le pont data de gâteaux comme
âgées aux japonais et puis il a commencé
son affaire au japon pendant 25 ans puis
la pensée de bergues affaire a au canada
ce gâteau est tellement populaire au
japon que plusieurs boutiques en font
leur spécialité l'oncle tetsu à 70
succursales partout dans le monde le
premier en amérique du nord a ouvert en
2015 à toronto et depuis l'été 2010 8
une autre succursale à montréal combien
de gâteaux par jour vous faites 5 5 un
gâteau au fromage beaucoup plus léger
que sa version new-yorkaise
il se vend au canada dans quelques
pâtisseries et des bistrots japonais
neko fujita et critique culinaire et
inconditionnel du gâteau de l'enquêté
dessous ma mère faisait souvent pour moi
quand j'étais petit
donc pour moi ce n'est pas un gâteau
japonais mais c'est le goût d'enfance
pour moi c'est un dessert qui peut se
vanter d'avoir beaucoup voyagé après la
deuxième guerre mondiale
c'est les soldats américains qui ont
apporté le gâteau au fromage au style
new yorkaise mais et pâtissiers ont
essayé de chercher quelque chose plus
plus léger plus bas moins de sucre ce
sont les blancs 2 qui font la différence
sur la texture l'exécution de la recette
des gâteaux au fromage demande de savoir
faire et beaucoup de précision on
utilise par exemple du lait à la place
de crem à fouetter
donc c'est moins qu'à leurs yeux est
plus léger et aussi au lieu de tuer une
étuve le gâteau omettons de l'eau chaude
sur le plaque du four comme ça la
texture devient c'est à dire le gâteau
devient plus gonflé tous les matins et
mis la pâtissière et toute son équipe
préparent les gâteaux qui se vendent à
la sortie du four à partir d'ingrédients
locaux deux saveurs nature ou chocolat
et une autre à l'essai il y a aussi un
autre serveur java que je préfère c'est
le avec le thé vert matcha le japonais
le match le thé vert en poutre donc le
gâteau et aux couleurs de thé vert et le
match à c'est pas tous les jours non en
fait jusqu'à aujourd'hui en bande
pis si c'est populaire on peut peut-être
le commence
c'est tout nouveau prêt de bon on est
devant le magasin on voit que c'est
coloré vous emballages le son legato
leçon c'est important qu'ils aient tout
ça oui on aime ça
louge puis c'est très coloré
et très sympathique que pour tout le
monde donc c'est possible tease clara
coloris qu'est ce que ça veut dire le
rouge pour les japonais qu'est-ce que ça
symbolise c'est comme félicité quelque
chose comme mariage dès 9 heures tous
les matins on fait le fil pour ces
petits gâteaux et les amateurs ne sont
pas que japonais je l'aimais surtout
payet froid devrait gérer les plus
somptueux il est vraiment bon je préfère
même sens au régulier cheesecake qu'on
connaît mais il comme plus trois filles
parlez-moi de l'aspect visuel du gâteau
parce que c'est très différent aussi du
gâteau meilleur kerry est très simple la
présentation très simple mais au milieu
au centre du gâteau surface on voit bien
le marquage de en cours d'étude le
marquage sur les produits alimentaires
ca c est traditionnelle au japon je
fasse quelque chose qui se fait pas
juste pour qu'on comprenne commencé
c'est léger c'est vraiment parce que les
gens vont comprendre comment c'est
évidemment c'est comme un coussin un
trade ou juste comme un nuage exactement
nous légèrement sucré sa fille disparaît
communes comme un poème japonais
[Musique]